like i took a deep breath i was like
oh my god as soon as
[Music]
monster as per
i cheated on monster the other day what
do you have
oh god that's good that um rain
you seen it it's a black can it's got
like a spartan helmet on the front or
something
maybe like r-e-i-g-n right yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe
maybe rings a bell it was all right man
it's got more caffeine than a monster
um so obviously monster haven't reached
out
there people haven't reached out to me
yet so
so you might be doing a switcheroo don't
thin ice that i could switch
i don't owe them [ __ ] i could switch
so guys special announcement
as of november
thanks to all the hard work you guys
have been doing with the mission 1k
um all the patreon subscriptions are
going um up up up up up
again if you're new to the show um
mission 1k means once we hit 1000 pounds
on patreon
we'll be doing two episodes a week so as
a thank you guys we're not there yet but
as a thank you for for what we've got so
far
we are gonna give you guys two episodes
a week for the month of november
so throughout november jump in two
episodes a week
monday and thursday enjoy
and uh we move from there that's gonna
be according to the calendar that's
gonna be nine episodes in that month
nine episodes yeah yeah nine episodes so
nine episodes
throughout november should be a fun time
and then
um obviously once we hit finish off that
1k we'll get
two episodes every year absolutely
patterned
so yeah ma'am exciting times um
fun fact yeah um have you ever heard of
the midnight sun
do you know what that is the midnight
sun
[Music]
i have but i i fear i can't remember so
go on so there are like there are a few
places in countries in the world that
have sun for 24 hours
so midnight sun is even though the sun
has technically set it's still daylight
so there's places in norway there's
places i think in like iceland around
that region
around the arctic region yeah so that's
a bit it's a cheeky fun fact like
if you go to i think if you go in around
summer obviously around like july
or so so if you're looking for some good
good places to go july and for some good
weather
if you go to iceland norway i think
there's one or two or more other
countries i can't remember
you get sun all day literally all day
yeah that's like um in alaska
i'm pretty sure they have it for a month
i think alaska could be one of the spots
as well i'm pretty sure in their last
one
three yeah during the year at one point
they have sun for a month
it's crazy it doesn't set that's crazy
that that
that will be mind-blowing are we
knackered because you wouldn't know what
which way is up or which way
you wouldn't know that from right ah i
need some guidance
and they have night as well for a month
yeah they've got night for a month yeah
it's weird that
that's depression i'm gonna be depressed
is that what's the same for like
normally
i don't know about that but i know there
is there is a spot as well where they've
got
i don't know if it's night for a month
or they've got night for
23 hours of the day certainly like oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah one hour of
daylight
yeah absolutely people get seriously
depressed in that environment
yeah i would i bet i'm getting depressed
in grace guys here
so yeah 100 i would be depressed with
that right trash news
nice where is it where the fudge is it
so yay
why are you saying it like that because
it's japanese
kabedon okay no i haven't
is that you know chinese racist
japanese people are crazy so
in um i don't know if you'd like this is
my best interpretation
but in japan they have like these
kind of categories of mail
okay so and female as well like they've
got like
cutesy girl and all this stuff and then
like the guys so they have like
fads that go through and those fads are
literally based on like
anime okay or manga okay and there is
um one that's called
like a herbivore so i don't know if you
know
so the population in um japan is is
struggling they're too advanced with
porn
and this like anime craze and like the
guys are not interested in [ __ ]
the women japanese women oh wow okay
they have no interest in [ __ ]
japanese women
and they call themselves like sexual
herbivores oh wow they're just not fast
so it's a herbivore is a as a type of uh
of character if you will
where a guy will be
he'll he'll literally just be like super
good looking so much anime
and they've got those guys that are good
looking but they don't show any interest
in the yeah
and then yeah yeah there's always like
the new guy at school in it yeah yeah
yeah then you guys called it rosie yeah
yeah all these
guys don't [ __ ] about any of them yeah
so that's a her before
and um they've they've tried to
introduce this new
archetype that the women might find more
attractive because obviously
these men are tired of being herbivores
now they're no one's getting any [ __ ]
so to encourage people
to start [ __ ] a little bit more
they've introduced this cabin daunting
right
okay so um this is
where so cabardon is the um
it's the thing you know when you're
chatting to a girl
and you get like a little bit more
aggressive so there's a face-to-face
thing
and you slam your hand against the wall
so you pin them against the wall and you
slam your hand against
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah i'll show you a picture and you'll
understand i think so
like this thing yeah
so you just get them against the wall
yeah you have to you actually have to
slam your hand against the wall for for
it to be cabled on
okay um and apparently the the women
find it a little bit more
sexually aggressive and it turns on and
stuff so there's like classes where they
teach you how to be more
like a cabardon character if you're if
you're classically a herb before
and you want to start busting nuts that
you have to teach you to be more
sexually aggressive so
this introduces cabern thing well what
the [ __ ] it's crazy
they lived their life as a comic book in
japan
that's literally how they live it
doesn't make any sense that is weird as
[ __ ]
it is weird it's extremely weird as [ __ ]
speaking of
anime characters is it is it in tokyo
that are doing the next olympics
i think so is it he was supposed to be
and then it got cancelled yeah so
they were meant to be showing the flags
you know the flags of each country they
were going to show them anime characters
have you seen that before no yeah i saw
them i saw it on twitter the other day
so they had with one with japan one with
i think was brazil one with
uh china one with it was crazy it just
looked good it looks sick
that would have been so [ __ ] it looks
sick it looks so sick the chinese guy
was like a samurai
all red and obviously like the the star
and i think it was doing something like
this
the japanese guy obviously had a samurai
sword i think it was either brazilian or
south african
had like some flares in the body it just
looked cool it just looked i think it
was brazilian like a capoeira esque type
yeah
look that's wild look cool i'm here for
that
they're they're imaginative yeah japan
is sick
they're on the next wave japan is sick i
want to go to japan i was just about to
say i want to go there and i definitely
want to do that mario karting on the
street
because a lot of people do that they've
got like you can do real-life mario kart
on japan road
what do you mean you don't know that no
what are you on about what you're
actually trying to say when you say
mario kart what do you mean
i mean like you can wear costumes rent
carts
and buzz around japan just anywhere i
don't know
anywhere but i've seen it like i've seen
it on people's instagram so we've got a
thing yeah
so i'm just up as mario do i have like
do they give me mushrooms i don't know i
don't know the details i just know you
can do that that's sick
it's very sick that sounds dangerous
though but
bless bless you brother i can't tell you
i can only imagine
um what japanese netflix is like must be
anime galore
i would love to stream japanese netflix
well they've got a vp ending
um i'm sure a short story for a vp
ending where you
you know when you used to be able to
change your country on there
they locked it you can do that now if
you pay for a service you can do it
okay um so but then you might have to
watch anime
without subtitles then didn't it if
you're hacking into japanese
netflix yeah but i'm sure every night oh
yeah everything has
subtitles anyway you're right you're
right you're right you're right
they must have ridiculous anime in japan
netflix yeah
it'll be it'll be a thing it will be a
thing i need a new anime anyone that's
listening to this episode today
recommend me a new anime please because
obviously someone commented the other
day
and was like oh if you're into sport
anime watch ace of diamond i think
and i was going to start watching it i
think i saw that comment yeah i was
going to start watching it i saw that
coming
um and i will start watching it but i
mean i don't know i'm in the middle of
watching one piece now
you said so it's hard work i started
watching one piece
two years ago i think i got to like
episode 80 odd or 60 odd
yeah it just i just fell off it's boring
is why
it gets [ __ ] boring but where am i i
think i'm on like 112
112 um and i'm starting to enjoy it
i'm starting to get invested in the
characters a little bit more so yeah but
there's like a thousand episodes i know
i know i know i just can't bother man
the thing is the only reason i'm doing
it is because i always moan
that when i find a new anime or someone
suggesting anime for me it's got like 12
apps yeah and i've banged through it
like a day and i'm like mate someone
find me a long long long thing
yeah and one piece the most famous anime
of them all is just sitting there
within [ __ ] a thousand episodes and
i'm like nah it's just that's too much
though
i think you know what is i think it's
because it's i don't think it's too much
for me
it's just that i've been told a million
times that it doesn't get good i feel
like episode 200 until like episode 200
it's like you're asking me 200 episodes
of [ __ ] to gain context
and it is actually [ __ ] it's boring but
you need the context yeah exactly you
can't just jump
but um they've got quite a lot of
fillers in there so i found a filler
list so i can skip through
big clumps of it when i found that i was
like oh yes just bang for it but um
yeah man i definitely need a new anime
to watch though
definitely did you did you ever watch
the ring i got reincarnated into slime
something like that yeah yeah watch that
one yeah yeah they're bringing a season
two out
soon and they're bringing out a season
season five
of my hero i think comes out early next
year
gang they've got to wait for demon
slayer movie coming out
october this month yeah okay
i'm excited for that i [ __ ] love
demonstrator yeah yeah so they got
demons there coming it's a movie
it's a movie that is part of the anime
yeah i thought so and um
what else have they got um there's bear
enemy that you haven't watched that you
should watch though bro
oh i need the recommendation um re-zero
you've told me about that before
amazing uh that's on there you know
that's no
that one's on crunchyroll okay um i'll
see if i've got any spare
devices on crunchyroll that you can just
use mine it's going to be on my anime up
anyway i've got a i've got a website
you'll watch all my anime oh okay here
r0 will be on there okay um god of high
school is new new though that i've been
watching
that's good um what else so re zero
god of high school i've been watching
did you ever watch haikyuu
no that's why i said netflix yeah yeah
gang
said the volleyball thing yeah could
have sounded high school
there it's a volleyball team
these won't get you hype i've seen the
i've seen the little trailer that show
up in the beginning but the trailer is a
part of an episode it's not a trailer oh
okay hey
yeah you want a trailer yeah cause it
makes me want to watch it when it's a
bit episode because it doesn't show me
the whole thing it's
really a [ __ ] cliffhanger yeah yeah
yeah but it does it does look okay but
i've just never been into sport animes
i'm more into like
if it's not shown in all like
psychological thriller yeah that's what
i'm into
yeah yeah there's supposed to be a good
psychological one called
i think it's called monster i'm not sure
but i think it might be called monster
and that's supposed to be a very good
psychological thriller okay
i love a psychological um and what else
is there that i've been watching
uh i think that might be here actually
that fireforce is cool fire force
yeah there's a newish one that one's
pretty dope fireforce
easy watch okay um yeah you can binge
there's bear anime okay i need it man i
need it because it's been a while since
i've been something
obviously since corona hit they've
stopped they stopped so much
yeah yeah yeah yeah they stopped
everything yeah man yeah i need
something new
so i'm excited for that gangnam um
i was going to ask you a question but
let me ask you if i've got any fan
requests because i feel like they're
probably clogging up
so let's have a look see
let me ask you a question where do you
think the boundary not the boundary but
the line is between
history and mythology
elaborate for me so
obviously history is history is history
but it's word of mouth at the end of the
day
yeah and so is mythology but where's the
line where's the what's the difference
between a where where does the line draw
between history and mythology in a sense
of
you can probably date back to like 18
whatever because you can prove that this
has happened so it's history
but mythology is stuff you can't prove
yes
but we probably just can't prove it
because the timeline is done now it's so
so far in the past yeah yeah yeah yeah
that is just claimed as a myth
but where does the line draw i know what
you mean you know what i mean
yeah i know what you mean it's so weird
i don't know why i thought about that
there is stuff like that all the time
that i think that is technically a
mythology i guess
but everything has to be stemmed from
something from something yeah you know i
mean
um and i remember that's like
when i was watching is it called
stranger
or is it called is that an anime or is
it
no it's the jason bateman thing
um jason bateman it's
monday nah it was on i want to say it
was on now tv
i don't think i've seen that um
what's it about it's about it's
basically about the boogeyman basically
where
um it's about a character right so
i'll try not to i won't spoil this one
i'm gonna give it a brief
it's live okay okay cool so but if
you're not all right cool
fine then if you insist so
this is a small town yeah and it's um
where a murders happened
jason bateman's in jason bateman
directed it as well i think i've seen it
have you it was on netflix i think maybe
not
i've said this before and it wasn't but
let's go again go continue yeah where
basically he
is filmed murdering someone now he
murders a kid okay
and he's walking around with blood all
over him no this is not what i've seen
yeah and jason bateman like is jason
bateman
but basically he's i know exactly what
you're talking about it's called
we've just yeah we've seen this have we
yeah you told me about this yeah i told
you about it
it's called [ __ ] what's it called it's
something right like the stranger or
something right
it's not yes yeah but it's not me and
bella watched it as well
it's like 10 episodes on skype yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] what's it called sky atlantic
it's
on it's called the
the something it's called it's not the
stranger
it's not because the strangers are
different in that watch as well it's
like a hosting it's the
i know what it's called what's it called
the outsider sorry outsider yeah
what a show sometimes i don't like
people saying it when i think it's on
the tip of my tongue
the [ __ ] outsider what a show yeah i
guess i've seen it
um right cool yeah so you can say
whatever you want about it now i know
i've seen it's a [ __ ] great show
it is it is um and you told me about
that show when we were in damn
oh i did yeah the outside is fantastic
so yeah anyone i'm not going to spoil it
with this one for you
watch the outsider it's just [ __ ]
amazing jason bateman is the king he's a
great he's a [ __ ] great actor um
right i've got a phone request yeah hit
me so hi guys i'm a huge fan
of the podcast i was hoping you guys
could help me out with my problem
i have a question so basically all my
life have been quite shy or rather
afraid to approach girls in a romantic
way
i have female friends but
i'm basically scared of rejection
recently my friend gave me a false
um sense of hope and told me a girl was
into me
and if i would ask her out she would say
yes
long story short i built up the courage
told her how i felt and basically got
my first rejection right now i'm doing
okay
that's not funny but
i'm laughing there's something else that
happened earlier
right now i'm doing okay good good great
but now i'm basically afraid of asking
out another one i tried to let it go but
every time i think of a gun in a
romantic way i'm reminded of that moment
what should i do pierce if you're gonna
answer this on the podcast please don't
say my name
tough i think i saw this but i didn't
really play i think i saw it i think i
saw it
cool right so your homeboy said oh this
thing is down
you should ask her out you don't see me
at your school exactly
exactly what happens is exactly what
happened to me
and let me tell you however many years
it's been since i'm still fit
i'm still fearful
this is some good water it was good work
sometimes h2o just
cleanses you i know that's what it's
meant to do sometimes sometimes it
tastes like sugar do you know what i
mean when it's doing this job it tastes
like [ __ ] sugar ah
sorry to divert from the fan request
um so homeboy told let's say you told me
the thing is feeling me moved to her and
she's not down so you basically lie to
me i lie to your face
and he's [ __ ] up he's courage to go to
another thing yeah
yeah yeah what do you do what do you do
to be honest
there's nothing you can do it's life
like at the end of the day you're gonna
have to move to a ticket eventually
um so you either have to wallow in your
own like
pity or like self-doubt or just bite the
bullet and take the courage to just move
to things whether you get rejected or
not because it's part of life
and i know it's easy for me to say now
because i'm 29 years old and i'm
assuming you're not
you're not like my age that's my
assumption
um because you wouldn't be my age if you
go through that right now i'm assuming
my assumption anyway your guy is a
[ __ ] childish prick yeah
yeah my assumption but um it's just a
part of life man it's a part of you
growing you just have to
you have to go through that [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
[ __ ] happens obviously that was out of
your control because
your friend told you one thing when in
reality it was another thing so that's
obviously a bit [ __ ] but your friend did
it for laughs and your friends are [ __ ]
so yeah your friends are better
um i actually was uh listening to a
different podcast and someone said
someone was talking about a completely
different situation but they said
something that kind of resonates
and it works with this in that like he
feels now
that because of what his friend's done
yeah he's taken the confidence he had
even if he wasn't very confident in the
first place he's taken away his
confidence and ability to talk to girls
okay and the the thing that they were
talking about wasn't anything to do with
girls and survivor was about someone
taking your confidence away from you
there was a guy seeing this therapist
and he told the therapist oh because of
xyz like i've lost my confidence
a man said how can you lose your
confidence it's your
confidence it belongs to you you can't
lose it
it's yours you own it you can't lose
your confidence
um and i think that applies to this
situation that's a very good is that
it's your confidence bro
and regardless if you're scared what did
we say before if you can't beat the fear
just do it scared
man that's all you have to do is just do
it scared and it
sucks and like at least you got the
first rejection out the way out of the
way
it's a [ __ ] one to get oh it's a [ __ ]
one to get yeah man
it's a [ __ ] once again but in perfectly
honest i would rather get this kind of
one
yeah than one that i was actually down
for
and i just like i was talking we talked
about this before
um i don't think actually no you might
not been there but this time but i was
talking
within a group of friends we're talking
about um when you propose
to your woman and then you get those
guys that propose to their woman and she
says no
and they're like oh i definitely wasn't
there you weren't dead
um but it was like oh how would you feel
if you proposed to your woman and she
said no
and obviously i i everyone said what
they said but it was a bit like
how has there ever been a situation ever
in life where someone's proposed to the
woman and she said no
like how did you read that situation so
wrong so wrong how could you get that so
[ __ ] wrong yeah like how is that
possible yeah
um and like that's like this one like
i'd rather get this kind of rejection
where your boy set you up you moved to
the thing and she wasn't down and you
could be like all right fair play
like cool whereas instead of a different
situation
where you're reading vibes yourself yeah
and you're thinking oh she's definitely
down
and then you move to her and then you
get rejected that would [ __ ] my
confidence up
because then i'd be thinking how did i
read this so right wrong yeah i was
certain she was down
i think maybe i think guys that
get rejected in terms of the proposed
thing is um
it could boil down to how do i word it
them being naive about the relationship
itself so let's say for example
um that person is in a rocky
relationship and they feel like
a proposal is going to win it all back
so i feel like that could be
i've seen that firsthand that could or
really i've seen that firsthand oh wow
i've never
that could be that could be why
men do that um that's my assumption
anyway that definitely is that's an
example definitely is
for a guy will do that if he thinks he's
punching and he's scared
just based on the vibes that he's
getting from the woman that he's just
like a
uh mr right now i'm not a mr right if
you feel like i missed her right now
and you're you're gas of this woman
you'll do dumb [ __ ] like [ __ ] propose
and buy an expensive ass ring yeah mom
and then when she says yes you're like
gang
i'm now i'm not gonna lose i can breathe
and then she [ __ ] off anyway it's not
allowed to live
that's she takes the bring with her
stuff but um
yeah man i mean yeah you're afraid to
yeah i can understand bro like you're
afraid to talk to
a girl in a romantic way now because
you're scared she's going to reject you
yeah
at the end of the day bro you're just
going to have to do it scared and
potentially at your age it's more common
to
at your age i'm assuming it's more
common like just when i was younger it's
a bit more common and it's a bit more
formal
yeah in like the courting process like
you actually have to physic when you're
younger
you're in more positions where you
actually have to physically say stuff
like obviously he said this boy said ah
if you ask her out she's going to say
yeah yeah like
in this day and age you don't just ask a
girl like you could say
to me like oh there's a thing down there
if you ask her out like she's probably
gonna say yeah
i heard she likes you i'll be like what
are you what are you on about what's her
instagram
that's what's her instagram that's what
it starts yeah yeah
i'm just gonna go out and ask a stranger
out yeah like i'm gonna do my own due
diligence thank you very much
so oh
i'm sure in your situations the courting
process is a little bit more formal
where you're in positions where you
actually have to physically ask someone
something
but later on down the line you don't
have to really worry about
you don't have to worry about the
potential for rejection because
it doesn't have to be as forward as that
it can just be nuanced man you can just
chat you could just
see what go on and then the romantic
like i would assume
live your life as if there's all as long
as you're a male and she's a female yeah
and you're both heterosexual just assume
there's always a chance
that she's down yeah because there
probably is a chance that she's down you
know i mean like
it's actually few options where you're
just plutonic friends with a female yeah
so if you guys are chatting all the way
just assume that she's probably at least
a bit down yeah
i hear that and take it from there man
um but yeah you're gonna have to do it
scared bro that's unfortunately it's
probably not the best advice but you're
just gonna have to
sack up and just [ __ ] do it you're
gonna have to man um
your friends are pricked for doing that
clearly but
at the end of the day you just have to
move on from that and that will probably
build up your
your tolerance of rejection maybe i
don't know
because you can't really get any much
worse i
really can't because take it from me
nothing nothing is bad has happened
since that time happened
with renting lauren i had a feed was it
red tea laura renting lauren
yeah nothing in terms of females has
ever happened
from there popping out today nothing in
terms of females has ever
happened as bad as embarrassing as yeah
in my life since then so
take it from me bro it's only up from
here only up from there bro it's it's
minor so you'll get over it
and there'll be a painting around the
corner that will probably want to move
to you she will move to you she'll
stick it on you cuz girls stick it on
random a lot more than you man
thank you just wait for it wait just
wait for it wait till your teeth grow in
as james would say bro when you go into
your teeth my g
oh my god and then oh it's mad the first
time a girl grabs your tool
just uninvited and not in like a rapey
way like not just on roads
you know what i mean not just on-road
grabbing your dick but just in like a
sexual context yeah she just gets a
handful of dick
oh your life is about to change
cause
yes it's the best feeling oh god
you'll be so solid then you don't need
to be worried about all this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah once a girl grabs your dick it
doesn't you don't think about like he
doesn't want my confidence to talking to
god
[Laughter]
they're like wow this goes right it's
certified this goes down
certified no other option yeah man your
best option here is to find your girl
that's just going to use you for me
you don't need to be worrying about your
confidence in any of them just let
just find a girl who's down for getting
piped out true and then you're fine
you're fine man yeah it's part of life
yeah
i'm glad i'm not going to have those
first times ever again
[Laughter]
you know how we keep talking about
obviously how we want to quit our jobs
and stuff obviously everyone the world
knows it everyone that listens to us
knows it
um have you listened to big shaun's new
album did you try to do this to big
shoulder at all
a little bit i listen i actually haven't
listened album all i've listened to is
the dave chappelle track and that's it
okay the story thing um he's got a track
called
um harder than my demons and he's
talking about how he wants to work
harder than these demons
and there's a bar in there and the first
time i heard it resonated with me he
said
um as soon as i quit my real job was
when the real work started
okay and it's just like i took a deep
breath
i was like oh my god as soon as we quit
our jobs the real work obviously we're
working now
but it we've got no backup plan oh i
know
it scared me a little bit bro i took a
deep breath
bro that's why we've said before like i
know
when push comes to shove and the day
that i'm supposed to quit arrives
i'll put it off for a couple more months
i'm going to put it off
because i'll be too scared that notice
period is going to be extended bro
extended i'm going to be so [ __ ]
scared because then this is
nothing else now this is it pure income
this is it speaking of pure income
um your boys went shopping today
with some podcast money and we're
currently um studio hunting
so we think we found a potential spot
this is true
so the um the aesthetic could be getting
juicy for you guys
i hope you're excited i'm excited i'm
very gassed
i'm very good i'm excited so to think
yeah to think we were in a position
before
of nothing and it was only it's
what's weird to me it wasn't that long
ago yeah
it was only a few months ago when we
were like ah when we managed to get our
own studio
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah did you
say this on the pod or did we just say
it i've i'm proud
i know we've just said it but i i feel
like i've said it on the pod before
but yeah just like pipe dreams of when
the day we can do this and then we can
do that
and those days are steady they're still
coming now
before the tail end of this year we'll
you would see a video of us in a studio
yeah bro we'll be in the studio
in the next couple months next couple
months and um
it will be patterned it'll be nice it'll
be set up it'll be
banging and it's just yeah bro
shaking and moving and we're coming up
in the world and that's that's literally
thanks to you guys
all thanks to you man you guys are
paving the way
for us to to do better [ __ ] but um
this this goes on i didn't i didn't
think this was going to be a deep
episode but here we go oh no i love him
i love him as well you know me um so
do you have you ever had a situation
this is probably quite similar to what
we're talking about now like
a situation where you've realized
based on potentially stuff that's
happened in your life
yeah i don't know if this necessarily
applies to you i know it applies to me
but i'll be interested to see if it does
apply to you
okay where you realize oh where i'm at
is where i'm supposed to be um
and everything that i never knew that
was coming up towards this
is the reason i'm here so i'll give you
examples
right yeah so yeah i've found myself
always drawn to like my heroes per se
people have like celebrity heroes yeah
yeah yeah yeah and my heroes have never
been just like the typical ones
my heroes have always been people who
have managed
to monetize their ability
to be in [ __ ] idiots
okay so just being dumb okay doing dumb
[ __ ] okay
the people that have managed to monetize
that and become successful from that
yeah i've always been the guys that i'm
like wow
yeah wow so like for example we've got
like
thundercat who was listening to earlier
yeah if you ever listen to thundercats
lyrics
he chat [ __ ] yeah he chats [ __ ] but he
just puts a funky bass line on it
a man's making [ __ ] money from
talking [ __ ] on songs
same with tenacious d obviously you know
i love tennessee yeah yeah jack black
jack black and carl gasps like these men
just talk
[ __ ] about [ __ ] threesomes with
one yeah
and they've got a song called
drive-through when it's just literally
them
at a drive-through order and burgers so
i'm like these men
have made millions and sold out arenas
yeah for talking [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you've got like the guy i love
on instagram uh what's his name
mark rubella the guy that does the beats
in his room and he always wears the
kimono the white guy with the glasses
and he just does uh he just makes a
track on on the cuff
talking [ __ ] yeah and he's smashing it
he's smashing yeah he's like my favorite
guy on instagram
is that the let me set your titties baby
guy is that that bro
i think so probably let me see your
titties baby
is it that guy probably i think so maybe
i think that one i don't know if it's
him because i might be might be thinking
of two different guys but if it's him
i love that um i'll show you him now
yeah
i'll know if you see i always put him in
my story he's always in my story
rebelli this guy
i think it is him that's him yeah i
think he's probably done that because i
think that let me say guities was
oh it would have been time ago yeah man
man did a session with [ __ ] erica
badou the other day no way
he's killing it no way he's killing it
and like he was
one that just he does bear live shows
and he uh
moved from wherever he was to either l.a
or new york i can't remember which one
he lives in
just to make it just to chase the dream
but like
him chasing the dream is not the same as
someone else chasing the dreams
like he's creating his own niche where
he just makes up some beats
talks [ __ ] and somehow it's wonderful
and then people [ __ ] with it and he's
making money from it and he's like wow
like there's chasing the dream
whilst following a certain path and it's
chasing the drew by creating a path yeah
creating a path and being like no no
this is what i'm doing and i'm sticking
to it i'm sticking to it like he could
easily have copped out and been like uh
maybe i should just do normal yeah maybe
i should just
be a normal human yeah maybe i should
just be a normal guy maybe i should put
some clothes on yeah stop walking around
the kimono in my [ __ ] underwear
doing dumb [ __ ] but he's just like nah
bro this is me this is who i am this is
what i'm gonna do and i guarantee it's
gonna work
and um that's crazy bro and this is like
it's those are the kind of people and
the dave chappelle said dave chappelle
again
obviously he's my number one guy top guy
and i don't know he won an emmy the
other day
oh is it so he won an emmy for his
netflix special
i think it was the newest one sticks and
stones i think right
yeah i think it was the newest one he
won an me4 oh great
he's funny his acceptance speech brav
was so sick
in that it was basically him saying
like oh wow like he would like put on
this like front and he was like oh wow
that
i'm so surprised like i'm winning this
kind of thing because
all the critics were saying that it's
[ __ ] it's not funny
it's transphobic it's sexist it's racist
it's this it's that
like it's [ __ ] [ __ ] like all this
like pc critics
are saying that's dog [ __ ] that [ __ ]
bell's done all this stuff yeah he's
taking it too far
all this stuff and man's like here i am
i've won an emmy so shut the [ __ ] up and
he i think he said [ __ ] off forever
so all the critics [ __ ] off forever [ __ ]
and i was like that is literally it
right you just stick to your guns and
say this
is what this is me that's what i'm about
this is what i'm about people know what
i'm about this has always been me
i can subscribe to it or not it's your
problem and you you can't help but read
back comments and sometimes about
messages and critics and stuff like that
and then like obviously we get all the
time as well and it's just like oh maybe
you shouldn't be talking about this
maybe shouldn't be doing that or maybe
you shouldn't
like you guys should probably change
your name and you should do this like we
talked about like yesterday was
something yeah
i changed the name thing yeah you guys i
was probably one of our first like
not hurdles milestones but like it was
one of our first things that people
spoke about that we should change
whatever it was uh the name i was like
nah yeah i'm not doing that nah
like i i i it will work
like yeah if you change your name at
work or if you change this or maybe you
should do this it will work
and it's like nah nah nah nah we're
gonna do what we wanna do we're gonna do
what we want to do
shut up it's our vision yeah it's our
vision man and it's going to work
you guys don't you guys don't think it's
going to work but it is and today we
went [ __ ]
studio shopping because it does [ __ ]
work bro
now spot me quick quick
does work and we stuck to our guns and
it's working oh and i'm so
pumped because no one else said it was
going to work
no one else no one else
everyone said everyone said it wasn't
going to work that's not true
literally like four people said it
wasn't like no but like it's those ones
when i look at those other people and
i'm just like [ __ ]
like those are the people that i chase
after i'm just like these dudes make
sense created their own part that makes
sense yeah creating your own path is
crazy and they were unrelenting and they
never they
they listen to everyone saying change
change change change change you need to
change you need to change if you're ever
going to be anything you need to change
because they probably won't have role
mode role models in a sense oh
they've got no one to follow no there's
no blueprints
man it's just like and it's
people love to say like oh i don't buy
into comments i don't read comments but
no one can
i know peop comments affect people yeah
you can't ignore you can't ignore you
you can like you can try your best you
can try your best but you got to read
some yeah
sometimes they just catch you on the
wrong day and you're just like [ __ ]
maybe they're right it's inevitable
maybe this random troll is right
and then you start second guessing
yourself but yeah so the people that
that clearly have definitely second
guessed themselves yeah
um i know that mark guys 100
second guessed himself in terms of what
his
his vision for his life is but here he
is man he's crushing it he's actually
he's [ __ ] smashing it man so yeah
stuff like that
um resonates with me do you know when we
when um obviously we've spoken about
what we're going to be like in five
years 10 years etc
and let's use musicians for example like
so obviously i spoke about big sean
before
we were talking about harder my demons
obviously not obviously but
people i've listened to big sean for
quite a while now
and the first like one of these first
commercial tracks was that our song
dancers that was one of his first
commercials
um but obviously he's been making
mixtapes before that yeah yeah yeah
i think they were called uh
almost something famous something to be
famous finally famous one two three that
was
finally famous one two and three
but that was probably 11 years ago
his first one but obviously because
we we because as consumers
of music we don't tap into their
day-to-day lives yeah we only tap into
what they release yeah yeah
yeah so when artists say stuff like
um my life your entertainment kind of
thing
it's literally like this is what they do
to put food on their table
and so when people say when people say
uh
like let's take 10 years down the line
people like drake for example or big
sean for example they're mate they're
rich or whatever
it took them so long to get to that
stage so in comparison for example jeff
bezos
so he's obviously everyone who's jeff
bezos is amazon
and amazon's been going for what 15
years if that years maybe even longer
so a lot of people give him stick for
not not like
giving his money away to help this and
help that and blah blah blah
and what people might not realize is
a lot of people do things in silence
yeah
the click bait would be jeff bezos is
not
founded in 1994 1994
there you go 1994. that's three i was
three
three yeah we were three we were three
that was jeff bezos was questioning when
we were three years old
he's been 1994.
he's been working no wonder he's got
what what is it 200 billion
something ridiculous that's all the
bills he's got all the billions got all
the money
and what what the media does is like
you would never ever see oh jeff bezos
has donated to this charity or jeff
bezos has
started this um trust fund you know i
mean they'll never show that they'll
only show oh he's made x amount of money
and what you can do with his amount of
money yeah
it makes you feel like oh this this
guy's an [ __ ] this guy's an awesome
right guys and also
right he's been working since 19 not
working but he's started amazon since
1994 and he was probably doing another
thing before amazon started
like he's 26 years he's been in his bag
and it's not even been that big for it's
only been a big one the last 10 years
yeah so amazon said it was just books
for time
it was just books amazon was i didn't
even know what amazon was back then
it's just [ __ ] both that was all
digital yeah bro that was all digital
now he's
banging he's like the best bag it's the
best it's the most popular company on
the planet earth
of course and he's been ever since he
started the company 26 years ago
man's been working working bro
so it's like you can't really say it's
easy for this man or this man's got too
much money but like
if you put hard work in for 26 years of
your life
do you think you're just going to want
to dash your money away bro of course
not like that's the thing
about perspective people don't also
think about like you never know what
he's doing behind the scenes that's what
i'm saying because they were always
even if they are he's doing good stuff
it's not clickbait it's not
it's not enough to grab holds people's
attention exactly i
if i saw a headline that said oh jeff
bezos has donated 1 million to
x charity here's the blog or it says
jeff bezos has 200 billion dollars
see what you can do with 200 billion
obviously i'm clicking that one right
because it's clickbait yeah yeah you're
intrigued with what you can do with 2
billion right 20 billion or 200 billion
rather
he's so rich he's ridiculously rich but
it's all clipped like a lot of people
paid obviously i don't know him
personally i don't know his lifestyle
if he is an [ __ ] i don't know do you
know what i mean but i'm pretty sure
he's not
um but yeah man it's it's it's hard to
it's hard to critique someone that's
in their prime now because just because
you don't know what they've been through
in the last 10 15 20 years
right it's hard to people only ever see
their pr their prime yeah that's exactly
like what you said
about like um the artist thing you said
a few weeks ago yeah yeah yeah yeah when
they did like gold quick
you're not paying me for now this quick
you'll pay me for the 15 years or
wherever it took for me to learn that
yeah bro
the reason should you be in 10 seconds
the reason why no one can afford for
drake to just
jump on something is because he's been
working for years drake has been working
i knew i knew of drake
since 2009 i knew of drake before i knew
you
there you go there you go i've been
listening to drake before i knew
you were you who you were he's been
working for years
and people but people don't think about
that people think about drink now no
now and it's his massive [ __ ] house
and if you think oh this
oh this or that jake has been
was acting before he was [ __ ] he's
been busy as a kid
he's been busy since he was a teenager
he's 34 33 now he's earned it man
he's [ __ ] earned it same yeah big
shaunting earned it
earned it these men are working so yeah
that's what uh i don't know man i feel
like that's a bit of perspective for you
guys not for you guys that are listening
watching but for like other people that
if you hear people say this and that
about people like they just probably
don't know perspective
a lot of people have to go through so
much to be so successful or whatever but
you're only focusing
on their success on their success now
you've not focused or you've not even
took the time or taking the time to
read or like know who they were 10 years
ago when they were grafting
and like do you know what i mean bro 100
huge is a huge difference yeah man and
it's the same with like um
it's the same with it sounds stupid but
like the animating i was on about
earlier
so like one piece yes i can say oh one
piece is boring one piece is boring yeah
yeah but when someone says to me
one piece is the greatest anime there
ever was i'm not gonna sit here and say
it's not yeah
because they have got a thousand
episodes yeah yeah yeah yeah they've got
they've been here yeah they've been here
for years yeah
i could never say you're not 1999 no
really something like that so
based on the animation that i'm seeing
that doesn't surprise me yeah yeah
because it was yeah it was dead back
i've been doing it for years and years
and years so when someone steps to me
and says one piece is the greatest anime
going
yeah i can't say any different because
they've been working they have been
working they've been working 1997.
97 1997. so one piece has been out since
i was what
six six oh my god yeah
so yeah man i can't say [ __ ] about one
piece which is why i'm giving it the
chance now
true i can't say [ __ ] so yeah bro
consistency and hard work always pays
off i don't care what anyone says
always pays oh yeah for sure consistency
and hard work for sure
again what i said i know we already said
it earlier like shooting for the stars
in my opinion pays off because like yeah
when you're surrounded by
crabs oh this is reddit taking you out
yeah so yeah i was talking to who had
earlier
about like reddit right so basically i
was chilling the other day and i had a
couple hours to kill
and i just went on reddit for some
reason and i don't really spend much
time on reddit i just went into a hole
on reddit
and there's a a podcasting subreddit on
there so there's a huge thread of like
just people posting [ __ ] and i'm like oh
this is obviously it resonates so i'm
like all right let's see what people say
and i've never done it before so a lot
of people go on there when they want to
start
people going on there they haven't
started yet they're like oh i'm just
about to start and i just wanted to hear
from some people that have been doing it
for a while like what are your expect
what should my expectations be like how
many episodes should i do a week how
often this and that and that
and everyone's just crabbing do you know
what to say i'm about crabbing no
i don't go and read it at all oh no no
nothing to do with ready okay crabbing
is just what i'm saying okay so crab in
if you're a crab it's when they say have
you had the analogy of like
um crabs in a bucket so if you put one
crab in a bucket yeah
it will climb out and get out okay if
you put 100 crabs in the bucket
every time one tries to to climb out
another one will grab it and pull it
down
oh it makes sense now yeah yeah so bare
people on these
on this podcast thread were just crabs
bro okay like anytime someone's starting
out they're just like cool
just to let you know off but i've been
doing it for this many years
don't expect to be making money in this
amount of time don't expect this don't
expect you're going to be the next joe
rogan don't respect this
and all this stuff and i'm like [ __ ] if
i would have
gone on here before all of this was this
yeah
i would have had such a different
perspective you've been demotivated i
would have been demotivated from the
jump and i was like all right cool man
well it's probably going to be 10 years
before anything really starts to happen
so maybe
there's no point there's no rush we
don't need to start doing this now we
don't need to start doing this now or
making that effort
making the effort now and i'm like yeah
well george in texas he's 10 years in
and he was a bit famous already when he
started so
all this stuff and it's like [ __ ] that
yeah
[ __ ] that bro i posted on one there was
one on there
that one guy was like oh i've just
started out like
obviously i'm intrigued about the the
success stories and the money stories
and stuff like that
like i just i just like to hear some
people's like opinions
bro bear people were like yo
i make this much i've been doing it like
i said one donny he makes like a couple
hundred pound a month he's like almond
episode 528
and another guy was like yeah it's ten
times more than what we were on
yes and i was like jesus christ couple
hundred
bro and he was i was like cool okay
that's quite a lot and another guy
jumped in there like yo
um i don't make anything but i've been
doing it for a few years and this this
like you shouldn't have much
expectations stop thinking about money
and all this stuff like
don't expect that you're just gonna be
able to quit your job and all this stuff
like bear crab [ __ ]
bear crab [ __ ] and then like i'm not i'm
not a commenter
i don't comment on nothing yeah i know
what you mean but i'm thinking this
guy's reading this stuff and he's
getting demotivated by the second
so i jumped in and i was like bro been
doing it a year this is how much we make
this is how much we make on merch this
is this someone's going to go in there
like i want to find out
[Laughter]
but i did i wasn't even signed in on i
didn't say what the pod was called or
anything like that yeah it wasn't even
my real name
it was just like an alias thing it's
already alias that they make up so i was
like this is how much we make on merch
this is how much we make on patreon this
is how much we make from youtube
uh we've been doing a year we do one
episode a week uh this is what we use to
promote ourselves
like dude [ __ ] these guys man shoot for
the stars yeah shoot for the stars it
doesn't matter what these guys say 100
it doesn't matter what they say i hope
you read
i really hope you read that um i'll
never know but yeah
i really hope you read it and thought
decent because this is the whole reason
i made the post i was looking for some
success stories
and all you guys are giving me is
[ __ ] um like they just want him to
be on their level yeah
and it's like because i think that's the
reality of it yeah exactly but
when people who are friends with joe
rogan decide to when joe rogan tells
them to start podcast
they start a podcast and they assume
they're going to be making not his money
but they assume they're going to be
making money yeah and they do yeah
like it's not it's not an accident it's
just they assume
that they're gonna be making money
there's a way to be making money they're
asking them oh what's the best method to
be making money doing this
he tells them xyz they use the platforms
that they have and they make money off
the jump
it's like you don't have to be stuck
with these crabs over here like just
shoot for the star just try
just try shoot for the [ __ ] stars why
not there's the results going to be the
same whether you have this [ __ ]
mentality or this higher mentality yeah
like if you believe
if you believe you're going to be a
success or you believe you're not going
to be a success you're writing them out
you're right now 100
so yeah bro i was just like man [ __ ] all
of this
just assume you're going to be the best
person ever
why would you not assume that like i
don't i don't really subscribe to like
managing expectations
i would like to just assume i'm just
going to be the [ __ ] it's a shame that
people
like live in that realm or are
associated with people that
crab per se as you said or drag them
down that's a shame
especially if like they have
self doubts as well they're going to
have loads of self doubts that's why
they were on there in the first place
mata i had mad self doubt oh i bet
i bet because of like we said before on
this that we didn't have any blueprint
or nothing it was just
it was just something we would do well
you decided to do and ask me and then
it's been winged from there kind of
thing
click and go thing and here we are a
year and a bit later
yeah bro so yeah i was just like [ __ ] it
now man
yeah it sucks that it's just like they
said like misery loves company in it
it just sucks that people would happily
like
not say like hey man i mean i've been
doing it for this much and it wasn't
even a case of like oh i'm proud of what
i make at this level yeah like it's cool
a lot of it was like oh just
it's cool that i make this much but
don't expect to be this this and this
is that's a shame and then like another
one was just like one and then you got
the other side of it
and just like obviously we're baby we're
baby but one guy was like
jumping in there like hey dude just let
you know like this is a different post
but it's like oh
hey guys like well i make this many
downloads a month now so
i thought i'd share just like top tips
of success on how to do stuff and i'm
reading it and i was like
bro we make like 10 times as many
downloads as you do like
shut up like shut up and people are like
oh man great advice but a lot of it
wasn't great advice it was more crap
[ __ ]
okay it was just that's the thing it was
it was just more crab [ __ ] crap don't do
this
do this don't do this do this don't do
this don't don't tell people what to do
man this is just like
this is this is how people express
themselves creatively creatively yeah
your own way
right yeah
let them do it the way they want to do
it like people are in there like i
really want to start like a
a crime solving podcast about this and
that and then the people comment and are
like
nah don't do that there's like it's too
much of a niche and i'm like
do it do it this is what you want a lot
of people who spoke to a finger
yesterday we spoke with a couple people
yesterday when
we had a few drinks um they
they binge what's it mystery murder
mystery murder party murder podcast
i'm not thinking i love mystery murder
series so i'm sure the puzzle bang
i'm sure bro anyone who puts enough um
time and effort into something yeah to
make it good
it's gonna be i don't care what the
niche is it's gonna [ __ ] bag it's
gonna be good um you've got no choice
but yeah man you want to do it am i the
[ __ ]
let's cool beans uh
let's see what we got
we did that one all right so
okay let's see this one new birch
cubbies suit guys
oh yeah don't forget we've had a few
designs we've got a few designs
so like i said before in a few episodes
ago it's going to be tail end of this
year
um i hope everyone
enjoyed the little one-year thing that
we did a little 20
off and got yourselves into a few bits
and bobs but yeah before the end of this
year we shall be releasing
a second season of merch um
we don't know how much stuff it's going
to be but it should be it should be some
good stuff we've got a few ideas as well
and it's been you found one you found
one you found one
yeah all right hit me cool so this one
got sent in to us
uh this week actually okay oh it's a
phantom idiot
yeah i've got bear them to get through
okay hit me um
so i like the fan ones because they're
just easier they're more relatable yeah
they seem more relatable yeah even
though the other ones are
technically fan ones because
they are they're where'd you get them
from is ready to get them from
they are technically fan ones anyway
because
this one isn't related to us regardless
true i know you mentioned do you know i
mean it's just yeah it's a fan related
one but it's just not ours
it's just a fun related one regardless
but anyway yeah
it just makes it seem a lot more
personal cool so am i the [ __ ] hey
guys love the part
i'm wondering if i'm the [ __ ] here or
i'm asking for permission to be one
cool right so i'm [ __ ] this guy on
the regular
and we're only [ __ ] no feelings at
the moment and i'm loving it
almost every time we're done uh he goes
home
but sometimes he asks to stay over i'm
not petty
and we can see that i think i've read it
i think i know who it is as well yeah
we can share a bed for a night the thing
is
he has eczema so he's scratching his
skin
this one and sometimes he leaves blood
stains
he's got rough eczema oh my god i have
tried to hold his
i've tried to hold his arms down while
he's sleeping but i just can't stop it
can i can i tell him he can't spend the
night
does that make me the [ __ ] oh and
also since he has black skin
and my sheets are white i remember you
can see the patches of skin
on the sheets when he leaves that bit
had me howled i remember that bit first
and
foremost i personally don't think you're
an [ __ ] for wanting
him to leave or not stay in the yard or
whatever
it's your space you do what you want
if he had the energy to come and link
you he's got the energy to bounce
that's what how how i see it i feel like
the x-meting
the x-meting shouldn't be as big of a
deal
as you're making it in terms of telling
him
because you both know he has eczema
this wasn't this wasn't a surprise right
you've linked him before you knew he had
he the first before he stayed over the
first time
you already knew he had ecma so this
shouldn't be an awkward conversation
right before you [ __ ] him you knew he
had ex
it's not a surprise to you so for you to
be saying oh i don't know whether i
should
um speak to him before asking him to
leave i have to [ __ ] hold him down
and blah blah blah
that's all long you put yourself in that
situation you should have been like
you should have said from the jump once
this that's done big man you're out be
out you were dancing there's no feelings
and stuff
yeah no feelings if you're if there's no
feelings then he's not gonna take it
personally if you're gonna be like you
have to bounce get your crocodile skin
out this is yours because
you're scaling this steroid cream what's
going on you need some
uh what's that what's it what's that
cream called for like bumps and stuff
pseudo is it pseudo crap
pseudocrystalline studio these are thick
dense pseudograms
there was one day i caught a rash
all over my inner thigh bro
this was about two months ago
as far as we're chafing my thighs were
chaffing [ __ ] hey i couldn't believe
it i
applied pseudocream pseudocreme i don't
know how it was gone really couldn't
believe it fam it was like magic
funniest thing yeah when um
so did you remember me telling you the
cockroach story ages ago when it wasn't
i think i think everyone remembers that
story cool game one of the funniest
stories
that makes me happy so that same trip
my boy mao caught the worst sun stroke
i've ever seen i don't even know what
sunshine looks like
i didn't know i didn't know what it was
until until i saw it
he woke up one day so we were out
so we've been there for about two days
yeah this is pre-cock [ __ ] on post
cockroach this is pre-cockroach
okay so we've been there for about two
days chilling yeah and then
one day the day two on the beach he's
just a bit itchy in it yeah yeah yeah
i think it's on stroke or some stroke
the one we feel faint i don't know
is anything is it the sunstroke or sun
rash or
i don't know heat rash is what it was
heat rash
heat rash okay okay heat rash
he's just itching a little bit yeah and
i'm like you good he's like yeah i'm
prone to be a heat rash it's fine did
you not put any spf on that he put
i don't think so maybe he did because
i'm just prone to being here
and i'm not all right cool bro so we get
back we go out that night
get home go to sleep all good
the next morning we all wake up i'm just
like
yo you man morning yeah i'm a bit
hungover still
and if um he wakes up like this his arms
are spread
his arms red legs are spread he's
starfishing in the bed
and his face is up and all i can hear is
him like
and i'm like what the [ __ ] from
that's like nah nah i look over
he looked like a shark he looked like a
reptile fan like an
alligator his skin was scaly no way
black and
scaly and i was like
what's that and man was like heat rash
he rashed
it looked the worst i've ever seen no
way you know like he needs to go to
hospital immediately
i've never seen any of you family he
couldn't go
out he couldn't go outside for pretty
much
the rest of the holiday no way in the
daytime he had to stay inside no way
then we bought him pseudocreme safflon
cocoa butter
anything his skin would drink it
his paws would back it it would be
rubbed in in seconds
fam i used to
we my mom was looking for all types of
remedies
i don't know what he'd do he had a
routine
yeah i'm snoring you're the routine
where there was a where our villa was or
wherever there was a lime tree that
would grow
from someone's garden it would grow over
a wall oh sick
see he would wake up in the morning run
yeah and grab some limes grab some
limestone
put them in the bowl why
what no it's acting like it was aloe
vera
it for some citrus in the bath to soothe
his skin
obviously that's gonna make it worse
it's gonna sting
the [ __ ] out of him so you'd walk in
and he'd be in his trunks laying in the
cars
floating in the cold waters just bare
limes popping in the water
and he's just there like
he was so fed up he was so fed up
in the night time my boy here cause i
said their beds were
put together right i was on the other
side
and in the night time you'd hear him
scratching
and then killed me in there like mal
stop and then like grab his hand
and then you'd look over and man would
yank his hand off him
he just kissed his teeth i keep itching
you're here just like shh and he's like
now stop
and he'll grab his hand he's like
you're so itchy [ __ ]
but it was the funniest [ __ ] thing
ever
man said the day before oh i just
suffered from mild healing
batman said i have mild health mild fam
he looked like a chameleon the next day
i've never seen anything like it it was
the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever and this was
pretty cocky
story cockroach just as it was starting
to ease up
that's when cockroach happened no wonder
he said he wanted to go home
it makes sense that's enough it makes
sense
but um anyway man let's wrap it up human
next week oh yeah you're not the
[ __ ] by the way
turn the bee out man distance buy some
cream and [ __ ] off yeah
get some steroid lotion of piss off
you